let's bring in Reggie Miller reg will be
on the call tonight Mavs and the
pelicans along with Kevin Harlan and
Kristen Ledlow that'll be 7:30 Eastern
on TNT reg good morning
hey any timeframe on Zion Williamson
wait what's the word in New Orleans from
what we are hearing we did their game a
couple weeks ago in Phoenix and David
Griffin did general manager president of
the pelicans told us mid-december is
that what's the timetable that's what
they had circled on their calendar I'm
not quite sure he's actually on the
court during court work so I don't know
if this is viable information but he
came up to me and said that right before
Christmas time perhaps you know the
unveiling of Zion can you be too
cautious with him they are going to be
cautious you know he is that type of
franchise changing player and they are
going to you know be very cautious and
you know if you want to call it load
management I don't think they're going
to overdo it especially you know the
first couple weeks as he comes back
because really no one's really seen them
other than him walking into the arena's
they haven't seen any court work so
again you know the weight issue I'm sure
is gonna come up and it's a mobility you
know how is he going to be able to move
with all that weight on those knees the
Bucks are now 18 and 3 they won 12 in a
row why is they don't seem to garner any
headlines why is that it's a lot like
you know San Antonio during those
championship years right they just play
you know the same way they have a
superstar obviously in Yanis on to
become Poe the MVP but other than that
the casual fan probably can't name
another Bucs player the hard core you
know the all-star and Chris militant but
because you name another Bucs player the
casual fan probably could not so they
fly under the radar they do play an
exciting brand of basketball
you know they put up a lot of threes to
get up and down they have a transcendent
player obviously an authentic kupo but a
lot like the Spurs during their
championship days people consider them
boring right
you know not exciting but what they are
doing especially for a small market is
unbelievable
and again the honest front-runner for
MVP I think you and I had talked about
this at the beginning of the season you
know who was gonna win MVP I thought it
was gonna be back to back he honest and
he's proving me right so far yeah I
would say LeBron has a I I think we look
at stories and I've said this a couple
of times on the program probably too
much but we've seen he honest we've seen
harden Luca who is getting a whole lot
of love and we've seen kind of a
reinvention of LeBron James and I think
that that helps him
although Anthony Davis may take some of
those votes away from him but I if I was
looking at how I think the media might
look at this award and they're voting on
it they would look at LeBron because now
you can write and tell a different story
then all the Greek freak yeah look at
those great numbers
and it feels like they want to tell a
story and the media as well will say you
know what
Yanis he's 24 25 he'll win plenty of
championships LeBrons on his you know
yeah on its long song it's LA it's
LeBron you've got a Mount Rushmore type
player in his 17 season we all know what
happened last year I'm only playing
50-plus games yeah let's go for LeBron
James
yeah be peace especially if he ends up
leading the league in assists and
averages you know 25 points for a guy to
do that in the 17th season is pretty
remarkable but I will say this you're
right Anthony Davis will take a lot of
the votes away from him
I was also wondering about this that we
look at the quarterbacking position and
we we sort of adjust according to your
age so we'll look at Tom Brady and go
you know is it 42 year old he's playing
ok or drew Brees as a 40 year old will
we do the same thing to LeBron
James and and grade him differently on
his age and mileage and I don't know if
we'll do that because it feels like the
critics are going to be there and they
can't wait for LeBron to actually you
know fall off the ledge like people you
know Patriot haters are waiting for
Brady to fall off the ledge and this
might be the year that happens but will
we will we grade LeBron a little bit
differently because of his age and how
long he's played in how many games on
that body I think that's just the nature
of the beast and yes we will grade and
probably it's unfair because what he's
doing in his 17th season is remarkable
we wouldn't be saying this if he was in
his seventh year right so I look at him
different because personally I can
attest in my 18th year it took
everything for me even to roll out of
bed to get to practice and for him to be
averaging a double-double and to be
playing at this high clip we we view
LeBron differently and we judge him
differently and a lot of times it's it
comes from him as well
right I mean he says and does things
that kind of you know push the meter but
we look at LeBron differently so yeah I
think at times he's judged unfairly oh
god man I wish I wish I could have been
playing like how he was playing this
late in his career in my career but also
don't you think he's making a statement
here because everybody wants to christen
you know Kawhi Leonard best player in
the game he's playing he'd said I don't
have load management here III think it's
one of those hey I'm old school
I don't need an old management and and
he's letting everybody know you know
that I don't need to sit down
back-to-back games I think it's a
Redemption year you know everyone was
counting them out and saying okay as you
just mentioned like you know the Tom
Brady haters at some point in time
father time is going to catch up to
these you know legendary players LeBron
is
bobbin and Weavin he's ducking you know
he keeps himself in pristine shape you
know Taco Tuesdays must be working out
there in California things are going
well for him right the Lakers are back
there winning the best record you know
in the West so hey more power to them
yeah but I load management would concern
me here and we say the same thing about
James Harden and the Rockets every year
like you know at some point yeah do they
have load management with James Harden I
don't know how you do this you know
every single night your team depends on
you to get at least 35 points and
everybody knows you're going to be
trying to get 35 or more and just that I
mean that takes a lot to do that every
single night in the NBA Peter more so
for James Harden you know I worry you
know I love the numbers that he's
putting up you know 60 through 3 look I
get it but at some point in time all
right someone else is gonna have to step
up and it's just a lot of wear and tear
at least LeBron has a D right yeah
at least he has a D and I think he's
taking their approach in you and I and
the Nets have talked about this on this
show I think the best course for LeBron
this season was to feed ad and run the
offense through ad which they've done
and LeBron is pictus is his points when
to be aggressive but he's been more of a
facilitator which is why he's leading
the league in assists so you ride the
young gun an ad harden doesn't have that
right and I just think over time I know
he's part of that old school to which I
love I love guys that can play hurt can
play back-to-back four and five I get it
I love that but at some point in time it
catches up to you and usually when it
does it comes around April to May Reggie
Miller joining us the Hall of Famer Mavs
pelicans tonight 7:30 Eastern on TNT
watching Luca which I'm sort of
fascinated how easy the game looks for
somebody who's in his second year
I'm still concerned about porzingis and
his involvement in that offense there it
still feels like he's a no by the way is
he is he completely healthy
well if he's on the court he's
completely healthy I just don't think
you know coming back and being away from
the game for almost 18 months I think
he's still feeling his way through and
when we did the Mavs Knicks games a few
weeks ago in in New York the way he was
moving out on the court it wasn't you
know Cornish like you know before he
played so free-flowing and I think a lot
of times he's he's out there thinking
again if the new system and it's a new
team in Dallas and Rick Carlisle and I
think they're learning to play with one
another with one another Luka and
porzingis and i think they'll figure it
out in time but i think once he gets his
legs yeah I don't think he has his legs
yet and that's just the better of being
away from the cordon playing at a high
level but I think once he gets his legs
because I think the skill set between
Don Cheech and and porzingis it's so
unique because both players can open up
the court because of their shooting and
both are great flashers but if you're
porzingis you're right he's not 100%
healthy but he's finding his way in this
new system in Dallas Carmelo Anthony got
Player of the Week now I didn't know yes
we were saying shouldn't they have
Comeback Player of the Week because yeah
I mean he was watching TV three weeks
ago and and it's a nice story but I'm
looking at some of the numbers other
people are putting up and average 39 Don
Cheech was averaging a triple-double
okay it's a nice little story it's a
fabulous story it's an I love hello and
I'm glad he's back but come on man come
on can Luca win the MVP this season yeah
he can but he won't not if Yanis
continues to play like this okay no I
think he is he might be slightly ahead
of harden right now if I was to rank I
would go Yanis probably LeBron Luca and
then James this Luca talk trash he does
really yeah he does in Slovenia
I really can't tell he you know what
he's more antagonistic towards the crowd
especially on the road so it'd be
curious to see tonight because he was
taunting a lot of those Knicks fans when
we were watching that game I mean that's
commonplace in the garden nowadays hey
you know what speaking of the Knicks man
we all know they're bad right yeah it's
time to start thinking about contraction
relegation what is going that is that's
bad man you can't have the Knicks this
bad well the Knicks and Warriors have
the same record but the warriors the
warriors I get wasn't supposed to be a
new lease on life for the Knicks season
Miller passion on the knee on oh yeah
but but didn't they have a really good
offseason isn't that what the apparently
okay and I saw a mock draft and and you
know obviously it's early that the
Knicks would have the number one pick
and they would take lamella ball I don't
know if that solves their problem
I think it might add to the problem they
would take the mellow over James Weisman
or Anthony Edwards well that that was
just the mock draft that I saw I don't
know what the with the Knicks do you
really know what they would do yeah you
don't don't know and I do think that
he's got a lot of talent but I do think
that you know he's bald dominant and
he's probably got bad habits because of
where he's played you know but he he he
can be better than his brother I agree
yeah I think he's guy I've watched too
much ball basketball through the years
when when he was a freshman in high
school I started watching him and you
know he's got some size I don't have a
home life by the way but um you know
he's got he's got sighs it feels like
he's a little more polished all around I
think he's a better shooter obviously
than his brother yeah yeah although I do
I want his brother to succeed I do do I
do
I want them the ball brothers yes I love
them but with them comes some baggage as
well it depends on who's coming with
them
yeah daddy dearest who's gonna be there
and that's that's usually not a good
thing but I will say you know if he's
gonna get two kids into the NBA that's
still pretty good
fantastic look at the holiday brothers
right yeah three in the NBA yeah that's
a ball and family credit to the parents
and you know the upbringing so I do give
the parents a lot of credit in the ball
family if you can get two kids in in any
professional sports that's unbelievable
he's going to be on the call tonight
Mavs pelicans tune in early 7:30 Eastern
on TNT reg have fun tonight
and what's the over no you can't do this
over under I can't do it over under
triple-double for Lucas or Luca yeah I
would definitely say be over nothing
he's gonna have a big number I think
he's gonna have a big night actually
coming off of that emotional high
breaking the Lakers 10 game winning
streak but don't you think it's
interesting reg if I said you put up 39
9 and 9
or you put up twenty ten and ten it
feels like people will look at the
triple-double as more impressive than
they go - I am - yes yes but you know
it's weird how we fall in love with that
that phrase that term the triple double
by Clay had a triple double
that's why Russell Westbrook won the MVP
because it was really simple for people
to understand it's like he had a triple
double yeah yeah nobody's had that since
Oscar Robertson yeah did you ever have a
triple double was it harder to get the
rebounds or the assists Oh to the Davis
boy and Rik Smits all right have fun
tonight reg and we'll talk to you next
week
all right that's Reggie Aloysius Miller
jr. the third for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]